streaming sketching and generally trying
to deal with very very large wraps okay
thank you and Patrick and thanks very
much for inviting me to speak so graph
streams algorithms so I'm going to talk
about problems in the following setting
so we have an input an input is just a
big long stream of edges and these edges
define a graph on n nodes and for the
sake of the talk will assume that n is
always known so here we are with my
nodes stream may just come in loading up
a graph over time okay the goal is to
compute something about this grab some
like your natural properties like maybe
starting up or something simple is it
connected is it bipartite stuff of that
nature the catch is though I want you to
compute these things as the date comes
in without storing the entire craft yeah
just a quick version so using 17 inches
there for ya for the sake of this model
yes but we will come back to that yeah
so edges right build up a graph over
time so we're trying to compute problems
on this graph without storing the entire
graph so the specific computational
constraints we have we have limited
working memory as we see this stream of
data we can't afford to store the entire
stream rather we might have memory
proportional to the number of nodes
rather than the number of edges or maybe
even less and available memory than that
we also have to process the edges in the
order they arrived we don't get to
choose the order in which we process the
data and lastly we want to process kind
of every new edge very quickly whatever
data structure we're maintaining we want
to update that data structure very
quickly okay and I want to clarify that
my student edges is armed tree I'm not
assuming anything about the grandpa
stochastically generated by some process
writing like this what I've defined so
far is a computational model so when
theoreticians theoretical computer
scientist of leads talk about kind of
graph streams they're talking about a
competition model in the same way talk
about the turing machine make a
computational model peter and a
computational model i'm talking about
the grandstream computational model but
that said shoe model is naturally suited
processing graphs that you learn about
all that evolved over time so
traditional motivations potato stream
processing I things like a monitoring
network traffic where you don't want to
kind of store all this traffic that goes
by and we can process this at the end of
the day rather you want to process it
online as it arrives without storing all
that traffic before you detect the
someone's breaking into your network
stream and wrote a relevant learn in
other applications for example if you
have a lot of a big data set kind of
stored in memory if you want to have a
good eye or efficient algorithm a kind
of a nice thing to do would be designed
album or work even if you just can't
scan through it's a stream through the
data on your external disk from the
periodical point of view there are
numerous interesting questions that
arise they can do what notions are the
Nazis or summary structures do we have
for graphs is if drunk if crash screams
is all about presents and some
processing things in some more space and
natural question is well how do we can
compress or summarize the data we return
process is the new other notions of
dimensionality reductions for graph data
what type of graph sampling is possible
it's a very rich aerialist connections
things like compressed sensing
communication complexity approximation
algorithms metric embedding okay and and
also if you even if you're not actually
interested in data streams per se may
the techniques that have been developed
are actually can more widely applicable
than just studying care outcomes in the
data stream model so in particular you
might have so this is the cluster the
theory group users at umass do you mind
okay no data distributed among these
machines in some are 30 carefully
designed way
yeah yeah but the fiber so Kara often
mainstreaming others that care for
foreign property that obviously at this
data on these different machines and if
each machine can have runs a day to mag
Romano's look at locally on its own data
and just communicates the state of the
data stream algorithm to some other
machine if the data stream Algrim
initially was only using small space
then cheap and easy to communicate that
state so you end up with a can have a
protocol or distribution algorithm that
uses a small amount of communication
which is important in many settings so
as I say I think extremes a great
believin feelin care about streaming as
many interesting techniques that apply
more genuine okay so this talk I want to
talk about cover three main or they'll
be three million sections at least first
of all I'm going to talk about some
success stories some like surprisingly
efficient algorithms you can actually
run in this severe computational model
and you can do things like kind of
summarize graphs in a certain sense and
compute various things interesting
things about grants I don't want to talk
about extensions of this basic model
like what happens if I was already a say
what happens at the edges that arrive at
some point disappears subsequently or
become stay after some time etc then I
want to chance some future directions
these directions i also want to kind of
i also cover the things some things you
can't do in data streams but rather than
can I give you a negative message saying
you can't do this you can't do that
indeed streams I can I want to phrase it
as a future direction is will work out
the exact problem you can solve that's
close enough to what you want rather
than drawing a recounting this is a
company survey that I was preparing kind
of earlier this month which means that
in this talk I'm not going to bother
kind of exciting who did wat etc if
you're interested and I hope you are we
going to have a look at the server you
can find us at this address it's also my
final slide so don't feel need to
feedback on this thing is is welcome as
well ok so Islands it sent some
directions any questions guess why are
you looking for recited realistic
answers or are you looking for answers
it depends on the problem so for some
problems will be able to solve the
problem in small space tutor mystically
exactly so the question like is the
graph connected or if not we'll be able
to deterministic Lee to do that for
other things we might be returning that
sometimes guarantee a 1 plus of time
approximation or two approximation and
maybe the alcohol works with probability
1 minus del through space depends on log
of one of adapter so that the point
deterministic and randomized islands are
awesome and exact albums so Alice so let
me tell you about so my first call to
tape at two synopsis data structures for
summarizing graphs in a certain sense
some these two you may already be coming
with them I would want to recap that the
two things I want to tell you about
first of all our grafts pacifiers and
graphs panels so first of all a graph
sparsa fire so let's suppose we have
this original graph here the original
graph G so a subgraph awaited sub graph
H we can call this a 1 plus of sound
sparsa fire original graph G if every
cut when measured in this graph is
within the weight of every cut we're
making this graph is within a 1 / such
an approximation of the weight of the
corresponding cut cut measured in the
original graph so Santa Jen every graph
has a bumper subs on Spotify just
because G would be a one person's on
spotify it for itself of course ok
what's surprising is that no matter what
graph you start off with G no matter how
dense it is there is always a one-person
son Sparta fire that is doesn't have
many edges and particularly no matter
how dense G is we can
ensure that H the Spotify graph only has
roughly n edges which is kind of cool
not only do these things is this but
they can be constructed efficiently and
they can offline setting and the
classical computation telling when you
have been tighter in front of you in the
search streams to be seen so the first
thing I want to show you is how
competing these things the stream is
really not that much hard work so i'm
going to show you that you can construct
one of these classifiers using only
slightly more memory than would require
to actually can move to store the spot
spire itself in the streaming setting
everyone final response fire is any
questions so there's actually a bunch of
work in this problem much of nice
complicated papers but there's now a
nice kind of simple algorithm this one
came up with and so that's implied room
works as follows so the idea is we're
going to recursively use and
off-the-shelf specification algorithm
and we're going to carefully make sure
the recursion is such that we never end
up using too much space okay so I said
we're going to recursively specify using
any standard off line graph
specification open so stream comes in
we're going to consider the street edges
in the stream coming in batches so e1 is
the first batch of edges there okay so
we're going to stall that we can stall
all those edges another batch of edges
come in we will store that package of
edges and all we're going to do is we're
going to take these two batches of edges
take the union of them and then
specifies the union of those edges okay
at which point we kind of come with
compressed down the edges in e1 e2 while
still preserving cuts and once you
forget about you want to edit it ok so
this point we're just keeping a
specification of the first two batches
of edges a third batch comes in we
remember that those edges fourth batch
comes in we run with those edges at this
point we can take the union of these two
batches
III unity for we can specify that and we
can forget about III and for at this
point we can sparse we're storing this
in memory throwing this in memory we can
put those together and response file so
these edges now have been sponsored by
twice so if every specification was
presenting things up don't want subs on
this double step this preserving things
up to factor 1 plus epsilon squared so
we can continue in this way v5 comes in
with sora t6 comes and restore it we
take the union we specify this stuff
keep going missing how much longer like
preparing an animation takes a fat fat
mention so he said that you can aight to
come in but we now these two guys of
memory put them together sparse if i put
these two top guys together and we
specify what you'll note i won't get any
careful analysis on the store girlfriend
keep it very light and proofs just to
try and give you the general intuition
is so this entire stream em there's
gonna be some like em edges so the depth
ministry is going to be it's going to
penn exactly how long these patches of
edges are but it's going to be a tie to
move to say log m or log n depth so the
error at these d round of specification
is going to be roughly 1 plus of sounds
of the deep and because of the way we
carefully did on a specification
recursively we can sure that we're only
keeping at most roughly d sparse graphs
at any one time so the overall space
ends up being kind of log n times the
space to store a single sparsa fire now
this is a one pass on to the d we wanted
one piece of silence we can just rip em
três for epsilon thanks okay not too
hard at all i hope any questions ok cool
so that was for ok so this careful in
terms of actually doing
approximating cuts less there's a more
powerful notion of graph specification
called spectral sponsor fires which
allows you to personally like spectral
properties of the graph like mixing
times I can pies etc and if all this
framework also works for aspect response
to feed from the same space you can do
simple services or cuts and spectral
properties you can do something similar
for distances via a summary structure
called a spanner so we have our original
graph here a son graph H is a case
banner for G if all graph distances are
preserved up to affect ok so by grab
distance I just mean the shortest the
smallest number of hops that's right i
mean the distance between two nodes u
and P it's just the small number of hops
between U and V so this is a sub graph
so distances will increase NH so for
example the distance between identities
on the fly well the distance is between
see well let's take three and six was
initially one and now it's three so
distances here have increased by mr. pad
for three so this was true for all pairs
it will get three spam ok so there's
also a data stream algorithm ok so once
you've concern i should say once you've
concern to the case banner of course you
can now proximate any just any the
distance between any two nodes up to a
factor k ok so the second sub are going
i want to show you or can tap is that if
you want to construct a 2t minus one
spanner so I think of T being a number
between kind of one-and-twenty a also
add two and twenty then there is an
algorithm that uses space roughly n to
the 1 plus 1 over T that will construct
such a spanner so if T is large you'll
be reducing your space for your
approximation factor will increase so
what is that simple algorithm that's
about
yourself I said okay yes it's I should
say it again since you asked and so the
yuca starts sort of doing the spectral
or cuts for others okay it's the overall
streaming space will be n pi log n times
1 epsilon squared so it'll just be Polly
load factors more than the space of that
you require just to hold the object a
running time overall it's going to be
some like ative employ log n just
because if you run if you use a fast off
the shelf offline specification
algorithm your it should have more ties
to worst-case login extra operate you
mean you at any one step you'll do it
most log n combines I'm not making any
claim about her item processing I think
it but I think in more ties it should be
ample again so okay too much running the
time yes i'm not talking about because
the limit i'm not talk about writing
time that much this span algum are going
to give you actually a very slow
algorithm it's space efficient but very
slow but it can if you need fast some
your table the argument but slow means
first ever at the end yet to do
something that's gonna be slow what is
the right time oh ok so in general i
think well in general we care primarily
about update time slow normally just
becomes a kind of crass garden design
question to get the push processing can
fast it's important but it's normally
not something that needs to be done a
fresh so the only for constructing a
spanner which is the sub graph such
edges don't blow so distances don't blow
up by too much so I just come in and the
idea is the next edge UV you're going to
store it no memory unless it can play
a small cycle and a small site is a
cycle of length 2 t minus 1 or less what
this okay so it just come in that 48 to
be dismal cycle so we ignore it that's
36 computers more cycles or what ignore
it etc so we'll just keep on going like
that it's not too hard to argue that
using this rule you preserve all
distances up to the fact that to t minus
1 why is this well you only need you for
a given edge UV you already go ignore
that edge if it completes a small cycle
if you complete a small cycle there was
already a path of length at most 2 t
minus 1 between the two endpoints so for
any edge you'd know you've already got a
detailed isn't too long and so for any
distance you can we build it up by a
secret of detours and it doesn't
increase the distance by too much the
argument for why this achieves the
claimed space bound that you never
actually you're never going to end up
storing too many edges in this angela is
actually based in some extreme local
parks result that says if you have a
graph that has no cycles of them to t or
less so if the girth is really large
then the density can only be like kind
of in this case engine one plus one of
the team ok so that's spanish to some
problems as i say like working out on a
project I'm does a edge complete a small
cycle naively if you imagine that that
they could take a long time for this way
to make the other one past so to mention
a couple of other algorithms that we've
had reasonable amount of success in one
is matchings so here I just come in
you're trying to compute a large set of
destroying edges by disjoint edges I
just mean that no two edges you store
share an end bond and there's algorithms
that use roughly Oh tilde n space that
will compute the two approximation to
the maximum cardinality matching or
consoles approximation to the maximum
weighted matching
many of these algorithms I can have are
based at the heart are based on greedy
albums and you can do better than these
constant factors people realize if you
assume something about the ordering of
the data so for example if the edges in
the stream I always always said you had
to kind of handle in an arbitrary order
and you're automatically correct no
matter what the order the edges came in
but if the HS your promise say a group
by endpoints you can get a better
approximation or if the edges arrive
random water people prove you can get a
paper approximation ok there's some
really nice recent work I can't see the
author's audience right now are
attending some of this to canoe some
more dill optimization Bob well cool
work and counting triangles sessions
going to talk about that mix I'll say no
more work on doing random walks the
streaming model simulating random walks
which is another way of like you're
trying to assess for the tune how close
related to notes two nodes are to each
other other work and start the immense
pantries check more the graphs bipartite
finding dense components correlation
clustering approximately independent
sets etc ok square root square of 8
passes passes the street yes exactly so
I realized I had multiple faster than
previous slide so I just made that
didn't come back to it now so my basic
model was just like if sequence edges of
arrive try and compute something of the
graph described to any given time but
there's first extensions let visit model
one of which is we could have this
notion that edges become stale after
some threshold time and so we could say
that we're even for this infinite stream
we're only that small mind small out of
memory and any given time you want to be
able to estimate properties of the most
recent say W edges so it's been fair
amount of activity in that area we can
solve most of the aforementioned
problems in this setting the question
here your multiple passes like often
if I don't if I let you so so far we
talked about taking one patch to the
stream if I allow you to take model
passes to the stream obviously obviously
you should be able to do more either in
terms of getting better accuracy or use
less space warm air this has been
successful in is approximating matchings
to fix there's also co work on annotated
streams this is where you can outsource
your stream computation make your this
guy who try to process a stream of data
and you imagine like a third party which
we normally call Merlin I could have
turned of communicate and communication
capacity results who may be kind of has
to make for information to help to aid
with your computational process of
confused something about the stream but
there the catch is that we don't want to
trust Merlin we want mounts a certified
competition here so we can verify that
certification this is all related to get
interactive protocols I'm happy see I'm
fast running at the time which means I
only have a second to allude to my nice
vignette about dynamic graphs dreams so
something that I've worked on quite a
bit recently is this case when edges can
both be added and removed from the
underlying graph can you still work out
with a graph disconnect in small space
it can if they can be edge removals
there's no fast way to go through this
animation my favorite example of a
dynamic graph is how many people seen
the movie the social network this is a
really cool movie so the movie starts
off with Mark Zuckerberg in his
then-girlfriend in a bar they're
chatting they're friends they're not
getting on too well though they're not
friends that's okay muscular other
friends it's one we company with Eduardo
he's being asked to get a right social
network by two twins Tyler and Cameron
and he's soon attracting the attention
of Silicon Valley bigwigs like Sean
Parker I was taking him to fancy my cot
this is all so much food water and
watermark on being friends
tyler and cameron realize what can march
up to this topic friends and the movie
ends over speakers okay why don't worry
that might be the one thing you take
away from the stir ok so don't graduate
who is a whole bunch of new problems
like for example previously if you knew
I just being deleted it's trivial to
kind of keep a uniform sample edges from
the graph and make some inference from
them if there's edge traditions you face
the problem that well maybe the edge
you've sampled so far this uniform from
the edges that haven't been deleted so
far maybe that's the so Caillou
remembering but maybe that's the guy
that gets deleted the next step in which
case is not a uniform sample from the
Romanian set but using kind of extreme
you two equal to l0 sampling is possible
to actually material uniform samples
edges in small space in the set of ok
there's other more powerful types of
sampling we can do ok sure the animation
bought me something so those have
something we can do and want to the
powerful form samplings we can we can go
through the stream and we can construct
a data structure such that at any point
you can give me a query and the query
will be a cut a partitioning of the
nodes and this data structure will allow
me to give you a random edge across that
cut and this is as you imagine very
powerful eyes only primitive that allows
you to do things like connectivity in
the dome setting in a similar space you
can also have sample edges with
probability proportional to the
reciprocal of them you can sample as you
be probably from portal 2 there's
typical the menu be cut and that's so
important sometimes that allows you to
can build convert oral specifies this
time setting so I can't really talk let
me let me skip this I don't really time
to go into the details of the sampling
things I was hoping to kind of show you
a quick surprising application of them
but let me instead jump to
where I think it might be interesting
future directions and extensions you can
always ask me about a previous slide
later so there's very specific open
problems you can take almost any album
result that mention the survey and try
and improve the approximation factor at
the running time or the space use
specific problems i'm very interested in
is can you construct the spectrums
pacifier in a dynamic setting with o
tilde n space you can over the best
urban so far uses auto the end to the
five third space can we can officially
construct Spanish and sliding window can
we improve comes back approximation pies
from match to the triangles if you go to
this Wikipedia this wiki this whole
interval problems on streaming and
properly testing just kind of future
directions one thing moving neglected is
in the stream community is processing
directed graphs like almost all the
atoms we've got so far off for
undirected graphs this is because there
are kind of information theoretic lower
bounds on how well you can and even into
simple directed questions using one pass
that you can't say for example is there
a path from u to V in a directed graph
like some like that and we can't do
unless you have a lot of passes but
people have done little quite how many
passes and it might be that with only
order log n passes you can add some many
many interesting directed problems
that's one direction I mentioned some
stuff about stream ordering like give
you a promise something but the ordinate
the edges maybe there's extra things you
can do and most I say much the work is
also focused on the case where you're
allowed order n space now for sparse
graphs this isn't much of achievement
because your graph is probably order in
the first place unfortunately lower
bounds still kick in and say these
things you can't do with less than order
n space I think a natural way to get
around this is to identify specific
families of graphs that you're
particularly interested in competing
about and try and design Agrium's
tailored for the specific boundaries of
graphs and thereby kind of like an avoid
these nasty little pads
there's also made deeper connections
with to anticipate outcomes
communication the place T dynamic crafty
disrupters they think of a deputy worth
exploring okay that's my summary we want
to have a look at a survey and I'm
definitely very happy you can email me
anything that doesn't make sense in the
survey or reference you think you've
missed that's where you'll find this out
thanks